pas saint-élie-de-caxton les petits
êtres magiques qui semble s'être propagé
à travers le pays peut être que c'est la
faute de saint-élie et la saskatchewan
n'y échappe pas une idée qui a la cote
auprès des enfants des parents et même
des profs
même quand ses lutins joue des tours
dans la classe de première année de
l'école st mary à regina geneviève tardy
et matinée comme les autres dans la
classe de madame bissonnette à l'école
sainte marie
mais il s'est produit quelque chose
durant la récréation
c'est leur nouveau compagnon de classe
bijoux qui leur a joué un tour le luth
et annie plein guimauve par terre puis à
plonger dans une montagne de sucre
ils ne sont pas les seuls à héberger un
lutin les petites créatures semblent
avoir envahi plusieurs maisons du pays
et même quelques salles de classe l'idée
est simple si vous attrapez 1,8 et il
faut en prendre soin jusqu'au 24
décembre journée où le luth et partir à
aider le père noël mais ce n'est pas
sans risque toutes les nuits bijoux et
les autres lutins s'éveille et joue des
tours ensuite une dame mais ça n'empêche
pas la petite sophia de beaucoup aimer
bijoux elle n'est pas la seule selon
leur enseignante
les enfants l'adorent oh il adore à
chaque matin la cherche dans la salle de
classe durant la journée c'est peut-être
quelqu'un écoute ou enfin mauvais coup
les autres élèves leur en fait rappelle
qu'elle est là puisqu'elle observe
puisqu'elle va rapporter au point de l
iut sont les yeux du père noël
c'est eux qui décideront si les enfants
étaient sages une idée qui enchante
chantal bissonnette absolument pour la
gestion votre porte
mais attention s'il y a une règle que
vous devez savoir c'est qu'il ne faut
pas toucher bijoux ok je le ferai
puisque le luth et perdra toute sa magie
et il en a bien besoin jusqu'à la veille
de noël ici j'aime bien tardif radio
canada regina et puis une sonde spatiale